yo I always say that it's for me it's
easy I separate the art from the artist
at all times and one of the best R Kelly
features ever is obviously
hotel which is on your first album that
was your first single right yes sir
um what was that process because I
always heard that R Kelly's like
processed as an artist was like he was
like a savant Like Rain Man type [__]
you know what I'm saying like what was
it like did you guys do that in studio
together
yeah so you get that was like you were
in a session with Kells as he's cutting
that what was that studio session like
um
it was my first time eating them and um
I think it was my first time to Chicago
too so you guys went to Chicago yeah
and um you know Switzerland was telling
me you know different stuff or how it
might be but when we went in there I'm a
super fan of R Kelly me too like my
older brother that raised me like you
know we used to ride around in the hood
banging that like banging R Kelly songs
loud like I was a super fan for sure so
to know that I'm working on my first
album finally got budgets open and it's
like big yeah and I'm working on my
first single with R Kelly and swiss
beats produced it crazy it's like
so I was excited I was super happy
um I got in the studio
um
and um even Twista came through I
remember twister came through the studio
and um
yeah and Twista like start rapping I
think
twist the spit some bars I spit some
bars
and um we basically me and swiss just
was there Swift started explaining the
record like hot was it swiss's idea to
do the the hotel concept or was it R
Kelly's idea
yeah it was Swiss out there
it was like a collaboration it was a we
we already had the idea that we wanted
to do this hotel record when we went to
go see R Kelly so it was already like an
idea we had we already had the beat
and we already like had the direction a
little bit but once you told R Kelly
like the idea he just went crazy in his
own Direction and started singing a
bunch of stuff he went in the booth and
went crazy and started doing a lot of
things that we could use for a hook so
he was doing he was just cutting
Melodies off the top of his head type
[__] yeah we just chose that little
piece that you know as the hotel core is
now but he did a lot of a lot of
different parts and a lot of different
other versions of hooks like we did the
remix too off the same session so it's
just parts of the parts that I told you
he did that we didn't use just for the
remix but there's so many ladies like he
just went in different bags he
creative man and [__] talented I forgot
to tell you too
before he went in the booth on a hotel
beat it was like a b tape playing of
like 30 beats just playing back to back
and he wouldn't say skip none of them he
wouldn't be like I don't like him or
nothing like that
is playing yeah it wasn't Swiss I don't
know who right but it was just a tape
playing and every beat that come on as
soon as the beat dropped he was singing
a dope record to it [__] sound like a
Smash Hit everyone I was like I was like
right off the top Hill he'll hear it
while the intro on as soon as the beat
dropped he starts singing some fire [__]
like and he did that [__] to Every Beat
like he kept doing it so I'm like yo
this [__] is not
um I think back to one of my favorite
records that was more like an album cut
you had a record called six minutes that
was it was you Wayne and Juelz right or
was it is that right I wish I got that
oh go back on the last question sorry I
wish I got a chance to like bust it up
anymore like really Jamar Kelly yeah
what type of Duty is because we never
really got a chance to what was the
video shoot like no it was the first
time I met him and then the second time
I met him was the video shoot yeah and I
never got a chance to meet him after
that yeah I really didn't like [__]
or kick like like kind of he did it feel
like he was kind of help like helping
Swizz out you know what I'm saying like
more like that yeah I mean it was my
first project I have no records out so I
really had nothing for him to really
right you know be connected to me it's
just I was connected to something big
which was full surface Swiss
um and then Jay records Clive Davis I
had to you know I mean were you one of
the first it was like You Alicia Keys
who else was on on Jay wasn't Baby
Records Mario was on J Records yeah I
feel like you were one of the first
people don't like I feel like it was I
feel like it was you or uh Alicia Keys
when I first saw saw Jay records Papa
yeah I was I was I was one of them you
know first
artist especially rappers yeah and I
mean yeah but you had I feel like I was
super excited because I had heard your
mixtape [__] I heard you on some mix
because I used to sell mixtapes at the
Swap Meet that's how I got my name and I
was like 15 16 so like
I remember just like there was I think
it was some funk Flex [__] you did
there was like a random Funk Flex
mixtape and he wasn't doing a lot of
mixtapes but it but you were you had a
verse on a mixtape that Flex was on or
something and I just yeah man I remember
just hearing like two or three me and my
best friend Ramses
man it was crazy too yeah I was super
prepared that was like battling in
Philly for years
um on this radio show called decipher so
by the time I got signed you're right
already
ready and then it took years for me to
actually go from getting signed because
I got signed a Rough Riders first when I
was 17.
and I ain't really come out with like my
first project till I was 21. so it was
like four years it's almost like rap
like like Kyle Camp College yeah and
then you graduated exactly